style you know it depends on the
fighters I'll give you an old-time
fighter who fought the wrong fight every
time Jerry quarry was a very very good
heavyweight he could do everything he
could box he could punch but somehow he
thought he could out bucks the boxers
now punched the punchers and those were
his losses he coming against Joe Frazier
give us a hell of a fight for six rounds
before he started bleeding or staggering
or something you know you look for
Styles a stylistic matchup you look at
the pluses look at the minuses the same
with a pitcher in a batter same with the
football team
I still remember Vince Lombardi's grade
line when his Green Bay Packers were
playing the New York Giants and the 62
championship game he said I'll tell them
what I'm gonna run if they can stop it
they win if they can't we win
I think boxing has an intellectual
aspect judge but shoberg a great writer
on the waterfront what makes Sammy run
love boxing
so does Joyce Carol Oates by the way
talking about literary types and bud
once had the great line boxing is a
sport is chess played with the human
bodies not on a board you've got to
think it now sometimes it's instinctive
sometimes the man's eye cueing too high
but his boxing IQ is so you watch him
think you know it's yes it's instinctive
but they've had they they've learned you
have to understand the word experience
really is learning from mistakes that's
that's experience just learning for
mistakes
and everyone has made a mistake whether
they won or lost because of it
they put that into their sort of mental
computer thou shalt not do it again so
you're looking for that
several Ally Joe Lewis Floyd Mayweather
yes films of Barney Ross films of
betting Leonard these are intelligent
fighters some have other attributes Ray
Leonard had probably the fastest hands I
ever saw some fighters have a great
knockout punch sometimes they can
combine it you know so you're looking
for a skill and will they meaning that
person be able to impose that skill and
their will on their opponent that's why
to me boxing is one of the most
beautiful sports in the world it's mano
a mano
it's like I once asked George Foreman I
said George we weren't interested in
football he said no I said why he said I
didn't want to be hit by somebody from
behind in other words they're there
no he said he was Muhammad Ali said he
was the greatest I don't think he was
the greatest I wrote a book called
boxing's greatest fighters I rated him
one to a hundred I think I have him
number six but this is pound for pound
not just heavyweight so I have him the
second highest rated heavyweight after
Joe Lewis because as Ray Robinson Sugar
Ray Robinson number one he could have
been number one through 12 but I had to
put another name or two in there but I
saw Ray Robinson so I'm knockout punch
going backwards which is like Nolan Ryan
throwing a fastball falling the second
base in terms of leverage but Ali's peak
years were the three and a half years he
was forbidden or prohibited from
fighting he was a dancing master and a
punching master what before the three
and a half years then he fails to step
forward for the draft is the equivalent
of disbarred for a lawyer for three and
a half years comes back and he goes to
rope-a-dope
those were his peak years so had he had
those and I can't fill him in he might
well have been exactly as he once took a
glove and dubbed himself the greatest
which parenthetically is a it's a line
he borrowed from gorgeous George the
wrestler who used to do that bravado if
I don't win I'm gonna crawl on my knees
to Russia if I don't win you know I'm
the prettiest and he'd lean over the
ropes gorgeous George and now he saw
that and adopted that again experience
he experienced watching him and
according to Angelo Dundee with whom I
wrote a book called my view from the
corner he was seated with Ali then clay
at a wrestling match in Las Vegas before
fight that clay had two nights later and
all Ali did watching gorgeous George was
it was what he said that's a good idea
that's a good idea and he adopted